[Music]
this is
[Music]
we begin tonight with breaking news on
just how unhinged the final days the
last administration were and how much
worse they might have gotten we have
some examples which are just now coming
to light america's top military
commander comparing then president
trump's rhetoric to hitler's and his
followers to brown shirts to nazis that
top commander finding himself rallying
subordinates to protect the peaceful
transfer of authority and perhaps even
head off a coup this is michael cohen
and you're listening to the maya culpa
podcast yesterday for what feels like
the first time president biden said out
loud what millions of voters have been
thinking for months have you no [ __ ]
shame i added the f-bomb for emphasis as
it's gotten to the point now where i'm
not sure we're living in a rational
society in america
if you lose
you accept the results
you follow the constitution
you try again
you don't call
facts fake
and then try to bring down the american
experiment just because you're unhappy
that's not statesmanship
[Music]
that's not statesmanship
that's selfishness if we were then after
the events of january 6th donald trump
had been barred from ever holding office
again and would remain a dark brown [ __ ]
stain on the collective pants of the gop
no one would pretend the event never
happened or played it down or try to
spin the moment into something positive
for fear of being in league with a
seditious violent plot to overthrow the
election of [ __ ] coup folks for
making no mistake
bullies and merchants of fear peddlers
of lies are threatening
the very foundation of our country
it gives me no pleasure to say this
i never thought my entire career i'd
ever have to say it instead we are
living in a mass hallucination a hall of
mirrors where the gop has lied and
distorted what happened and embraced a
[ __ ] dictator who continues to push
the absurd delusion that he won a second
term every time
the media references the election hoax
they say the fraud is unproven
and while there is no evidence no
evidence
no evidence there's so much evidence
you saw what happened in georgia the
other day they found 35 000 votes
then they deleted in georgia
over a hundred thousand votes i said
because they were so bad voters
i said why didn't you try doing it
before the election lost by this much
why didn't you do it before the election
there's bad things going on in this
country not only that to even remain
viable in the republican party it has
become de rigueur for those schmucks who
whitewash what happened
imbeciles like ron johnson picked up the
mantle claiming that he never feared for
his life because the rioters were
comprised of people who love this
country i knew those are people that
love this country that
truly respect law enforcement would
never do anything to break a law then
there was [ __ ] representative andrew
clyde who set out [ __ ] loud that the
violent scene that exploded at the
capitol on january 6th looked like a
normal tourist visit but last sunday
when trump took to the stage at cpac my
[ __ ] brain exploded as he took the
gaslighting and [ __ ] to the next
level rebranding the insurrection this
failed coup to overturn the election
which left five people dead and more
than a hundred police officers injured
as a peaceful gathering of patriots who
were justified in their actions they
think that we'll just sit there and take
it like good little boys that we won't
werewolf and go wild i have watched with
disbelief since january 6th while trump
and his most ardent supporters have
tried to memory hole what happened and
slowly shift the narrative from it being
an unfortunate incident to something
akin to woodstock for conservatives
what happened that day from your
standpoint fox business anchor maria
bartaroma asked trump who responded by
saying that the stop and steal rally
that preceded the insurrection had been
called by patriots who were merely
demonstrating spirit and faith and love
love there was such love at that rally
you had over a million people there they
were there for one reason the rigged
election they felt the election was
rigged that's why they were there and
they were peaceful people these were
great people
the crowd was unbelievable and i
mentioned the word love the love
the love in the air i've never seen
anything like it
and
you know that's why they went to
washington then he described one of the
people who broke into the capitol ashley
babbitt as an innocent wonderful
incredible woman before suggesting that
her being shot was an inside job by
democrats and possibly someone working
for senate majority leader chuck schumer
who shot ashley babbitt why are they
keeping that secret who was the
person
that shot an
innocent
wonderful
incredible woman
a military woman
right in the head
and there's no repercussions if that
were on the other side it would be the
biggest story in this country who shot
ashley babbitt earlier in the interview
trump also claimed that nancy pelosi was
in part to blame for what transpired on
january 6th having supposedly ignored
his call to have ten thousand national
guardsmen standing by
unsurprisingly everything trump said
during the interview was 100 [ __ ]
[ __ ] including the whopper tying
schumer to some kind of cover-up around
babbitt's death so i've heard that i
will tell you they know who shot ashley
babbitt they're protecting that person
i've heard also that it was the head of
security for a certain high official a
democrat and we'll see because it's
going to come out according to nbc's
news tom winter the officer who shot
babbitt was not a part of a specific
security detail to a member of congress
for a senior law enforcement official
and was most likely part of vice
president mike pence's detail
but what's even more frightening is this
latest attempt by trump to rewrite what
happened that day and cast himself as
his most lunatic supporters as the ones
who were wronged jonathan shaite wrote
of this last week in new york magazine
after trump began his all-out campaign
to turn babbitt into a manga martyr
trump has slowly turned january 6th from
a black mark that was threatened to
expunge him from republican politics to
a regrettable episode that his allies
preferred to leave behind to a glorious
uprising behind which he could rally his
art and supporters the
anti-anti-trump right has dismissed the
insurrection as overblown a protest
march gone bad perhaps ill-considered
but never posing any serious threat to
the public
the far-right highlighting of babbitt's
death sends a different message
the insurrection was good babbitt's
effort to penetrate the defensive
barrier was brave and the stopping of
her charge a crime
by throwing himself behind this message
trump is endorsing the most radical
interpretation of his presidency
january 6 was not a minor misstep after
a successful era as fans like mike pence
and lindsey graham now say it was the
heroic culmination of a righteous
uprising love at that rally and they
were peaceful people these were great
people
the crowd was unbelievable and i
mentioned the word love the love
the love in the air i've never seen
anything like it you have people with no
guns that walk down
and frankly the doors were open but
there was also a love fest between the
police the capitol police and the people
that walk down to the capitol people who
walk with no guns with no nothing and
they're tremendous in many cases
tremendous people tremendous people
[Music]
i cannot emphasize enough how dangerous
a message this is to send his already
delusional and [ __ ] unstable
followers
trump is far from done though i have
said before how a wounded trump is a
dangerous trump and now we are seeing
that manifest in his public statements
i don't need to recount to you the ways
in which trump is under siege
sure his business is crumbling and he
might very well go to prison
even his once-packed rallies have become
boring sideshows
so like any showman he's taking things
to their most extreme and appealing to
the most extreme of his base because
that's all that he has left as mitch
mcconnell said in his floor speech on
february 13th
trump loved this he loved what happened
on january 6 because it was all about
him these people were fighting for him
they were fighting against democracy and
against free elections to be sure but
they were fighting for him and that's
what he cares about and he's gone right
back to that he's continuing to lie
about the election lying about the crowd
size he's now back you know there's no
remorse there was never any remorse he's
out there on the loose now he's created
basically this cultish ad you know
adherence to the big lie david frum
writing in the atlantic this week
spelled out how this is nothing less
than trump in the gop embracing a new
kind of fascism
even in 2017 when he caused so much
uproar after refusing to condemn the
deadly racist attacks in charlottesville
saying that there were fine people on
both sides
spreading the blame equally amongst the
right and the left he did not dare to go
so far as to praise the far right
elements that weekend
from rights whatever he felt in his
heart he was constrained by certain
political and practical realities
his non-twitter actions as president
were filtered through bureaucracies
he had to work with republican
congressional allies who worried about
losing seats in congress in the next
election
he himself was still basking in the
illusion of the supposedly huge victory
in 2016 and hoping for a repeat in 2020
outright endorsement of lethal extremism
that was too much for trump in 2017 but
now look where we are you will never
give up our search for truth
and justice for what happened in the
corrupt presidential election of 2020
because without that truth we cannot
have an honest election in 2022 or 2024
no matter what they wanted
[Music]
in the first days after the january 6th
attack on the capital trump supporters
distanced themselves from its successes
the attack had nothing to do with trump
they argued he had urged only a peaceful
demonstration
if anybody did any harm that person was
a concealed agent of antifa
but in the months since the moon has
shifted once repudiated the attacks are
now accepted
condoned and even endorsed because
dictatorial socialists
want to cancel america
we have to fight back
to protect our country's greatness
they are attacking the foundational
principles that have combined to give us
the greatest nation in world history to
give us who we are
they attack our republic by engaging in
unparalleled voter fraud and election
theft activities
they attack our first amendment freedom
of speech
with
censorship from big tech with the cancel
culture
with speech suppression by government
activities
they attack freedom of religion their
view of religion is you can worship in
church but once you open those doors and
exit you can no longer have your
religious values that is not freedom of
religion
you have the right to live your religion
24 hours a day seven days a week
but that's not what the dictatorial
socialists are insisting and that's not
how they're changing america in the past
few days leading pro-trump figures and
even non-trump conservative figures have
endorsed a startling twitter thread by a
previously boutique podcaster daryl
cooper tucker carlson read the thread
aloud on his show in the end daryl
cooper writes not every theory about
election fraud is true but trump's
voters quote are absolutely right that
their government is monopolized by a
regime that believes they are beneath
representation and will observe no
limits to keep them getting it
end quote
that is true and every honest person
knows it the threat argued that the
january 6 protesters were right to
believe that they had been cheated out
of power they deserved
they were right to believe that the
government and the law were conspiring
against them
they were right to believe that their
opponents were capable of anything even
assassinating trump
the implication
they themselves were equally entitled to
go just as far it shows the real danger
that we're in even though that the fence
is coming down
i think in august there has to be
increased vigilance the president former
president
the former occupant of the white house
keeps repeating
false information that he will be
reinstated when that doesn't happen
because there is no way that it can
there is no legal or even fantas
fantastical way that it could happen
there will be people who will be
disappointed because the people who
listen to news from unverified sources
or listen to it on fox and oan and
newsmax believe that this is true
and they may react to it in the same way
they reacted to his uh urgings on
january 6th and just before january 6
and we could have another insurrection
what we now have is trump granting his
most lunatic supporters a license to
commit violence in his name
sure like everything else he does it was
oblique in its excitement but he is
leading them to water that's for sure
and the coming months may prove to be
the most violent and frightening we have
yet to know
that's a sound database
that's the sound of the police
[Music]
and now for the main event
my next guest on maya culpa is one of
the leading progressive voices working
today
david pakman's eponymous show first
broadcast once a week in northampton
massachusetts community radio has now
grown to become a mammoth nationally
syndicated series reaching millions of
listeners and is broadcast on both dish
and directv
in addition his youtube channel airs
daily content and boasts close to 1.4
million subscribers generating over 900
million views on any given day he can be
seen dissecting the gross negligence of
the gop
analyzing trump's cpac horror show or
discussing how the biden administration
should respond
in addition he has become a favorite
punching bag of joe rogan who has
sparred with pac-man of his own podcast
a number of times
the show features some of the most
extreme personalities on the right in
the hopes of exposing their views and
has become appointment viewing for
progressives seeking to fight back
against the current authoritarian push
he joins me today on maya culpa at a
perilous time for our democracy as
donald trump has shifted into his most
extreme iteration with the gop gleefully
following him down the rabbit hole so
let's listen now to that conversation so
yesterday in a rare address about the
2020 election president biden said and i
quote in america if you lose you accept
the results you follow the constitution
you don't call facts fake and then try
to bring down the american system just
because you're unhappy that's not
statesmanship that's selflessness
at this point what can should biden do
to stop trump from continuing to tear
apart his presidency and the country
with his lies about the election
well the reality is anything he does is
going to be attacked and so the most
important thing is what can he do to
just ensure
that in 2022 and in 2024
the actual winners are the people who
are announced as the winners and
ultimately hold the offices that they
won any anything joe biden does is going
to be attacked as an infringement on
free speech it's going to be attacked as
an attack on the election system itself
because everything's backwards right if
you if you want to defend the system so
that just
anybody who can vote can vote
the narrative right now from the people
that are remaining around trump and it's
not everybody who was originally around
him but there still are some
um is that no no the fight for electoral
integrity
is on the side of those who say that
it's the former president that won so
the best thing joe biden could do
is what can he do federally to prevent
the bills like the one that now is being
uh pushed in texas
from becoming law
and in so many other states and there's
a real question as to whether on on the
federal level you can get that done well
you know you're right there are very few
people that are around him today
especially in comparison to when he was
president for example rudy is no longer
around there and as we saw the press
announced the other day that it was rudy
that was actually telling trump and it
doesn't shock me because rudy's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's actually sitting
there and trying to placate trump and
during election night
after they told him that the beginning
you're gonna come out strong because as
we all know republicans go to the ballot
um you know to the um you know to the
ballot
box and the democrats tend to use
mail-in ballots substantially in greater
number and so rudy's comment is just
declare yourself the winner just each
and every state just declare yourself
the winner before the press announces it
or before the media announces it as if
that was going to actually change the
results so yeah we don't have that same
group about him but the people that are
still there and we're talking about the
you know the corey lewandowskis the dave
bosses you're talking about uh what's
the other idiot's name um
jason miller right these individuals
that are sitting there still surrounding
him are still playing to his fragile ego
which is that you lost the election six
months ago get the [ __ ] over it already
right move on well what i don't
understand is the report that you know
revealed this whole thing of rudy saying
what supposedly drunk rudy saying just
go out and say you won which is
ultimately what trump did the report
from the book is that people like jason
miller and bill stephen and mark meadows
at the time said you can't do that but
later they they seem to just fall in
line with it and i'm trying to
understand what the dynamics are are
they just captive like once once you do
that at 2am then they have to go with it
because they as far as the report is
they were saying don't do that
originally well and they probably did
say it now look i have zero regard for
either stephen or meadows especially
meadows who
i just find to be a despicable human
being um
one of the problems is you don't want to
fight with trump i've been in the room
i've been in that situation you just
don't want to fight with him so you will
tell him something that you know to be
right something that you know
is
response is responsible for the position
that you hold
and yet once he tells you no
well now what are you gonna do you're
gonna fight with somebody who's like a
five-year-old in a in a grown man's body
or who's going to sit there and attack
you in front of everybody you just don't
want to do it and so you say listen you
know what if this [ __ ] wants to make
these sort of ridiculous statements you
know it's on him it's not on me i did my
job i warned him you know it goes back
to that old expression you could lead a
horse to water but she can't force him
to drink that's donald trump you could
take his [ __ ] head and shove it into
the water right but he won't drink
and he is as stubborn as a mule so what
do you do you just say okay and then you
step away and you let him do whatever it
is that he wants it's the only one
statement that lewandowski used to say
that i actually agree with again and
again and again and that is let trump be
trump
because you can't stop him it's not like
corey was letting him be himself you
just can't stop him that's the problem
when you're dealing with a narcissistic
sociopath when you were advising him as
a lawyer like did it even matter that
you're the guy that knows the law or is
that completely secondary to just
whatever it is that he wants to see is
the outcome well is it any different
than the fact that he knows more than
his generals about war he knows more
than the scientists when it came to the
coronavirus than experts like dr fauci
or dr burks right epidemiologists that
have degrees that actually know what
they're talking about versus a guy who's
basically you know
coming from his you know from his gut
reaction who has never read a book in
his life so the answer is it makes no
difference if you're a lawyer or you're
not if you answer the way he wants you
to answer you're the guy who's right if
you answer contrary how many fights i've
had with that man over things that he
was doing wrong and you know it got to a
point that
he accepted my response whether it was
in favor of what he was looking to do or
contrary but he still always did what he
wanted to do very very rare now we also
talked about you know what can joe biden
do right now to stop this wave of you
know trumpism to stop the nonsense
that's going on with the continuation of
the misinformation
and the disinformation
that's being put out by him
and his
cohorts and i really do believe
that merrick garland our attorney
general has an obligation to start to
impanel special counsels on a regular
basis i don't care if he if he creates a
special counsel every day for the next
60 90 120 days until such time as
trump's individuals
and trump and his kids
and others are all held responsible
because i think the american people are
entitled to an answer and we just don't
get it it's almost like okay he's out of
office let's just all forget the last
four years and move on but you can't
because you know it's like the remnants
of a fart it just lingers there and it
just doesn't go away so you need to you
need to febreze that [ __ ] well this is
where i think republicans are just so
much more ruthless and and shrewd
than democrats have ever been because
you know look at the number of benghazi
hearings with hillary clinton
and look at what hap i mean you know you
could go back to bill clinton in the 90s
look at the obama which the obama quote
scandals which were not even real
scandals and they are shrewdly ruthless
or ruthlessly shrewd
and there is a sort of complacency that
i think is already pointing
to a a not good situation in 22 and 24
where hey you know what it is tough to
remove an incumbent and it was done
trump got four years and he was removed
but too many people are already
satisfied with that and i do think that
how do you justify
not doing the january 6 commission as
originally envisioned i know it's
looking like there's going to be
something done but not what was
what if this was reversed they would do
four years of hearings there's no even
iota of a doubt
oh absolutely i mean
they would be shredding the democrats
every single day there would be
at least a hundred open investigations
you would have mitch mcconnell
screaming from this bully pulpit every
single day about what hillary clinton is
doing or what whoever the democrat joe
biden is doing if it was reversed and
would he be justified absolutely he'd be
justified the american people
your employers have a right to know what
the [ __ ] went on and we don't and we're
more confused today than we were back
then and that's an unfair thing to put
us through and what happens is then you
have the media and they're creating
their own narrative
you know because they're trying to stay
ahead of the bloggers and that
everybody's now fighting and competing
for information and then instead of
getting actual facts you're just getting
in you and well i think you don't know
you have no idea what's going on you
actually have no baseline within which
to formulate a response other than the
fact that you're just either
regurgitating what somebody else has
said
or you're just sort of imposing your own
belief system but your belief system
doesn't matter when you're dealing with
trump and trump world because you don't
understand him you don't understand how
his mind works and even the guys who
were journalists that spoke to him you
know for a book right or spoke to him
for an article you know 30 years ago 20
years ago 10 years ago even last year
and they got 15 20 40 minutes an hour
with him you can't understand him he's
guarded when he's talking to press it's
another thing when you're sitting across
from him day in and day out for a decade
and a half and you really fully
understand him and the machinations of
the trump organization the books that
are the unauthorized you know the ones
that are not based on interviews with
him like we talked about this there's
this uh frankly i did when we did win
this election that's coming out and
there's another book from uh
lenign and philip rucker from the
washington post
the the the apparatus of trump just
immediately says all the anecdotes are
fake it's all made up it's anonymous
sources you can't believe any of it
which is totally predictable but as
someone who knew the guy is any of the
stuff that gets reported in those books
implausible
yeah yeah in in some of them i mean
there were a couple of books i don't
want to specifically state which one
because i would be [ __ ] on the
author right on this program and it's
not really right i'd rather get him or
her onto the program and ask them where
they got that information from and sort
of contradict it but so much of this
stuff is well yeah i was in the room
when he said no you weren't no you
weren't because that's not how he even
speaks and that's not what he would do
you see donald trump is actually much
easier to understand i talk a lot about
it in my own book he's very easy to
understand if you understand him if you
speak his [ __ ] up language right
then it's easy to understand what he's
thinking what he wants to do what he
will do because donald trump is a very
myopic individual
there's not this great range of thought
process
he's like history it'll repeat itself so
if donald trump for example has a steak
on monday chances are on tuesday he's
going to have the same steak in potatoes
or he'll make a derivative or he'll get
a hamburger right but he's very easy to
understand like for example you'll never
see him eat a piece of fish
right it's just not in his repertoire he
doesn't eat fish
for whatever his reasons may be so if
they write in a book that yeah we were
having dinner and donald was eating a
piece of salmon now
no no donald doesn't need him so it's
those details that signal to you as a
guy who was around him for so long that
some of the stuff is not plausible
absolutely absolutely and it's a shame
because
that lack of accuracy
is what trump uses in order to
continue promoting
fake news concepts the fact that the
media is disingenuous this is all
against him it's part of the witch hunt
and in many cases the media is wrong
they just happened to be wrong they
either didn't fact check properly you
know like all the people who wrote about
me being in prague
right i've never been to prague and so
trump will use something like that to
say she's fake news he's fake news they
got it wrong saying that cohen was in
prague and he paid 10 million in cash to
compromise off of that [ __ ] steel
dossier and he'll use that on something
that's absolutely 100
accurate and not only is it accurate
because we know it to be accurate we saw
it we heard it but he will still fight
it using an argument and then there's
this populist
this group of american americans 74
million uh right that voted for him and
then that 25 percent of the republican
party that believe every word he says no
matter how ridiculous how stupid how
absolutely you know
inaccurate it is
for example let me give you a quick
example on this one you know he's making
allegations or he had made allegations
that the
voice when he said grab him by the [ __ ]
when he was deal um on the bus with
billy bush
there was a time he was trying to make
the allegation that it wasn't his voice
that they did doctors that's right it
was doctored and so on now we all know
that it wasn't right but because
fake news had misreported something he
could then use that as the stepping
stone
as proof that this must be doctored
because i never said it
did you ever figure out with the prague
thing like at one point
there was the possibility that there was
just another guy named michael cohen who
did that thing and then at another point
the hypothesis was you know if if you
went but you didn't clear customs
technically you weren't in prague in a
legal sense like there were all these
different things do you know how that
ended up being a story no um i mean i
know that there were people like this
louise mensch as an example she wrote
that um i must have another passport
like an israeli passport because i'm a
jew
so not only not only is that not only is
it offensive right it's also inaccurate
i don't have an israeli passport in fact
i've never been to israel i intend on
going when i'm off home confinement it
would be the first trip in my life to
the middle east so the notion that i
have another passport the notion that i
got to germany somehow um and then
walked to prague i mean i i don't i
don't know there is no answer you know
and i used to say to the reporters that
would call me on it you could never
disprove a negative right so i can't
prove to you
you know that you're inaccurate if you
just keep wanting the inaccuracy to be
the story and it just doesn't work
after a year unlike any other we all
deserve some summer fun but be on the
lookout for new travel scams designed by
cyber criminals to steal your identity
help protect yourself online by being
mindful of online ads independently
verified deals with the company and
don't rush into giving away info on
suspicious websites
you put your information in so many
places online unfortunately cyber
criminals around the world keep finding
new ways to steal identities
the all-in-one protection of norton 360
with lifelock makes it easy to have
protection in the digital world
device security helps block cyber
criminals from stealing your personal
information
vpn with bank rate encryption helps keep
information you send over wi-fi safe
lifelock identity theft protection
monitors your personal information and
alerts you to potential threats
now no one can prevent all cyber crime
and identity theft or monitor all
transactions in all businesses but if
you have norton 360 with lifelock you
can opt into cyber safety
so sign up today and save 25
or more off your first year by going to
norton.com
cohen that's 25 off norton 360 with
lifelock norton dot com slash cohen
[Music]
but you know david let me ask you this
in a recent phone interview with fox
news maria bartiroma trump delivered his
most forceful support of the january
sixth riots to date in what was an
extraordinary set of lies even for him
right trump laid out what amounts to a
pivot towards his most extreme followers
the ex-president praised
ashley babbitt the woman slain as she
attempted to crash through the door that
protected members of congress from the
mob that had now invaded the capitol
innocent wonderful incredible woman
right so that's that's what he said and
then he you know he praised the
insurrectionist throng great people
then on top of that he denounced their
arrest and jailing as being unjust
now he also then implied that babbitt
had been shot by the personal security
detail of a leading member of congress
and i think he said i've heard also that
it was the head of security for a
certain high official a democrat it's
going to come out discuss with me if you
would these statements or at least the
tenor of these statements and what they
mean to you yeah it's extremely
dangerous i think even later in that
same interview
chuck schumer's name was floated and
everybody was sort of non-committal i
think maria bartoromo said she heard it
and trump trump didn't really comment on
that extraordinarily dangerous but also
think about the hypocrisy where we have
had for years situations where there's a
police interaction with someone
suspected maybe of having committed a
crime or there was just a 9-1-1 call and
it's not even clear there was a crime
and they get beaten or even in some
cases killed by police and very often
the refrain is well even having been
there was wrong they shouldn't even have
been there they would never would have
interacted with police and thus it never
would have happened
ashley babbitt
was trespassing already
this is the exact argument that they
typically make when the situation is
reversed
she could have avoided any interaction
with police just by staying home that
day she didn't have to go to washington
now it's still a tragedy that she died i
wish that she hadn't but an
investigation was done into the incident
there was not wrongdoing found and if
the situation were reversed the very
same people would be saying we've got to
stand by law enforcement it was
investigated there was no wrongdoing
found and the police that were there
were in harm's way we have to defer to
their assessment
of when force has to be used i mean it's
just pathetically hypocritical well
that's donald trump that's his middle
name hypocrite because he [ __ ] lies
like you breathe and i say that all the
time and i mean it for example you may
remember years ago when he claimed that
he was sending an entire or that he had
sent an entire investigative team to
hawaii and that they found out
information on obama's birth and just
wait
just wait till that info comes out it's
beautiful it's incredible just wait what
he's doing is he's playing with the
public because he doesn't believe that
the american people have longer than a
one to two week memory span
and sadly most of these followers do not
and they forget that he even brought it
up but here's the truth about that he
never sent anybody to hawaii there were
no investigators there was no
information but he tries to change the
he tries to change the narrative
by imposing his own set of facts
repeating them over and over again and
getting morons like maria bartaroma to
repeat the same [ __ ] as sean hannity or
[ __ ] tucker carlson or any of the
other bunch of you know white supremists
to continue to promote this ongoing
continuous lie and then ultimately
people start to believe it and then they
start to repeat it and they repeat it so
often that their friends start to repeat
it and that's the misinformation
campaign of donald trump but what i also
found to be amazing is that trump
actually
wanted to call for the name of the
officer who was involved in the shooting
and i want people to start to think
about why he's doing that because what
it does is
it then creates chaos and that's how
donald trump thrives he thrives on chaos
you cannot be looking at me my company
alan weiselberg rudy giuliani ivanka don
eric kushner you can't be looking at any
mac gates right um josh hawley you know
you name it you can't be looking at any
of these people because right now all we
need to concentrate is on that wonderful
beautiful person who was shot in the
face
and killed by a
you know by security for a top leading
democrat and we should know who that
person is could you imagine that this is
what this guy wants to do and yet
this is also here comes another big lie
by donald right
he's pro-police
he's pro-police
how do you respond to something like
this
yeah it's the pro-police story and then
the pro-troop story but really what it
is is the way i i now see it is
it's we're in favor of the institution
of law enforcement
as a way to wield power or we're in
favor of the military as an institution
to do our foreign policy but the
individual troops who come back and have
ptsd and we don't even give them access
to good health care
that's not really what it means to be in
favor of the troops right in favor of
the troops has a very narrow meaning
which is you allow a republican
president to send them wherever they
want to send them in order to accomplish
geopolitical goals it's not about the
individual troops and similarly it's not
about the individual police officers
it's about the police officers as an
apparatus to wield power and achieve
political gain whether it's clearing a
plaza for a photo op or whatever the
case may be you just have to he supports
the troops and the and the law
enforcement only insofar as the
institutions are useful to the political
goals
only is it's useful to him and his best
his political goals correct which is
nothing more than what he was doing
while watching the insurrection on
january 6. that was donald trump's
paramilitary that was his ability to be
reinstated as not president of the
united states but authoritarian um ruler
as the supreme ruler of this country
that he was going to stop the re
certification of joe biden as president
and be reinstated this is the nuttiness
that was going on inside of the brain of
donald trump because some idiot told him
that this could possibly happen and i'll
suspect that it was rudy right i really
do i believe it was probably rudy that
came up with this nonsense and it's
possible that the you know the hair dye
somehow seeped into his skin and
affected his brain that the synapses you
know weren't really firing the
acetylcholine wasn't you know wasn't
snapping from synapse to synapse and he
came up with this cockamamie [ __ ]
idea but he creates a real danger to
this country because
even the fact that it's absurd they
still decided to do it hey i will see
you at the capitol no you won't because
he's a chicken [ __ ] who went running
back to the white house for the sole
purpose of watching it on television and
now he wants to use the death of ashley
babbitt and i'm with you on this one no
one should have died that day but they
should not have also stormed nobody
should have been storming the capital
and you put yourself into a dangerous
situation and i'm really sorry for you
know for for her and for her family it's
just a loss of life for
a ridiculous ridiculous goal that could
never have been achieved so i don't
understand it and i'm i really am i'm i
hate to see anybody lose their life over
stupidity but that death is not on the
hands as far as i'm concerned of the
police officer that was protecting the
door you know to where the members of
congress were i blame trump for it i
blame rudy for it i blame don jr and
everybody else that gave a stupid
impassioned speech
about this is our country we have to
take it back we need to fight fight like
hell right i'll see you at the capitol
it's on their hands not on the police
officer but the sentiment that's coming
from trump and commentators like tucker
carlson and mo brooks is that all their
anger and violence was justified this
one really blows me away right they're
arguing that the january 6 protesters
were right to believe that they had been
cheated out of power that they deserved
now they were right to believe that the
government and the law were conspiring
against them this is what they believe
right you know that they were right to
believe that the government and the law
were conspiring um against them that
they were right to believe that their
opponents were capable capable of doing
anything even assassinating trump the
implication they themselves were equally
entitled to just as far
right to go
to just go as far as that they wanted
now with such a message being broadcast
should we be worried that trump is
setting the stage for more violence
whether it's in 2022 or in 2024
specifically 2024 and what point is
there a legal obligation to stop what's
happening with these sedition charges
yeah i i'm worried not only about 22 and
24 but i mean look at how much
discussion there's been of august over
the last few few months
and and whatever the expectation is
among the followers for for august as
well i don't want to be hyperbolic and
say i think there's imminently going to
be some riot i don't i don't think that
but i think january 6th proves that
these are people that are willing to do
things in the real world they're clearly
willing to take what they do on twitter
and wherever else and and push it into
the real world so it it has to be taken
seriously now
22 or 24 or what will be the trigger i
don't know you know you've got this this
mike pillow guy mike lindell from my
pillow who's going around and fomenting
a lot of this stuff and saying we're ju
we're on the verge we're like right
there we're about to do it and it's all
going to happen and when that doesn't
happen you know if if you fall for that
in the first place you're likely to be
very angry when it doesn't happen and
then all bets are off in terms of what
people are willing to do my hope is
michael
that
they're so unorganized that they just
won't be able to put it together because
i think there's every desire among you
only need a few thousand people to do
real damage and to wreak real havoc i
think the desire is there i'm hoping
they're just not organized enough to get
it done and the saddest part is you
actually hit the nail right on the head
we we cannot just hope and pray that
this doesn't happen and when it does
people start putting up the emoji of
their hands together you know my
thoughts and prayers are with you no no
it doesn't work that way it really
doesn't work that way
and i believe that joe biden's
administration including the fbi and
secret service our law enforcement who i
praise all the time on the show because
despite even what had happened with me i
have nothing but respect for law
enforcement for anyone that puts on the
uniform and i don't just mean military i
don't just mean you know i'm secret
service fbi i'm talking about all all
uniform firefighters police officers you
name it and i believe
that they are not just going to hope
that nothing happens
i believe that they are already
formulating if not already have a plan
in order to ensure that this [ __ ]
doesn't happen again not in august not
in 2022 and certainly not in 2024 and i
don't believe
that um nothing is going to happen i
believe something will happen but i
believe that our law enforcement our
intelligence agencies that are
monitoring this um you know
very very very carefully
that they will have more information
than obviously what either you or i do
and that they will put an end to this
very very quickly they will not allow
what happened on january 6 to happen
again under biden's watch but you're
right what happens when you have
thousand five thousand about fifty
thousand people getting together
armed and dangerous and willing willing
to sacrifice themselves for the supreme
leader that's what donald trump wants
you know the best way to become a
dictator is you stifle somebody's first
amendment rights
right and then you bring in the military
to take control of the government or in
this case a paramilitary a group of
idiots running around with trump you
know flags and you know maga flags and
they make america great again you know
paraphernalia that's really the
dangerous part now speaking just quickly
about august i personally don't believe
anything is going to happen in august
simply of course not right and mostly
because
dc is closed in august congress isn't
even in session so even if he was to be
somehow right the miracle of god that he
gets reinstated as president you can't
even do it properly
because congress isn't even in session
so it was just the wrong month for them
to have picked they showed that july
they should have said september but they
picked the worst month because nobody's
even there within which to reinstate him
as president
it's crazy speaking by the way i i if
this is a tangent we don't want to go
down then we let's not go down it but
because you mentioned if by the by the
grace of god trump is reinstated
the anti-semitism stuff right the people
who say
trump's obviously not an anti-semitic
guy
his daughter converted to judaism his
grandkids are jewish his son-in-law
who's jewish is in this position of
privilege in the administration and all
of this different stuff
to me that is meaningless i mean there's
everything from anti-semitism to
phylosemitism to people like the saudis
who want to do business with jews
because they think they're clever which
is still based on the same anti-semitic
tropes what's like the truth about
trump's personal view on that donald
trump doesn't care if you're jewish
christian but he does care if you're
muslim he he believes that all muslims
are actually islamic terrorists that's
that's in his mind but judaism
catholicism you know he doesn't care and
why because he has no religious
conviction of his own so the fact that
ivanka would he preferred her not to
have married a jew maybe yes maybe no he
didn't really care because he has never
himself been to church
except for the one time that he was
confirmed which is the picture that he
shows you know all the time right oh and
as he's you know holding the bible he
doesn't know the bible he doesn't
understand you know the meaning of
religion he's he's never sat for a
sermon or for mass right he just hasn't
and again he has no religious conviction
and all you have to do is just recall
when they asked him one time you know if
you
were to apologize or if you could go
into confession right from a mistake you
know what would that mistake have been i
don't i there's no need for me to you
know to go to confession or to you know
to apologize to god i've never made a
mistake this is a man who is incapable
of understanding anything other than
himself his personal wishes and his
personal wants because he's ignorant
he's arrogant and he's just stupid he's
just plain stupid and he believes in
nothing other than himself the world
starts and ends with him now you know
david let me just jump back into this in
philip rucker and carol lennon's
upcoming book i alone can fix it they
show the genesis of the big lie having
come from an allegedly drunken rudy
giuliani encouraging trump to just go
and claim the victory regardless of the
vote tally at the time that's what i was
talking about you know early on in this
in the show now even after arizona was
called for biden he still encouraged
trump to just go declare victory right
now now according to the book mark
meadows as you state it was vehemently
um against rudy's plan
what do you think actually changed in
mark meadows and the others who at least
displayed a shred of decency before this
election i think it's just once the cat
is out of the bag their only option is
either you quit
or
you publicly say i don't agree with that
in which case you're fired or you end up
just going with it with the calculation
that hey listen
maybe this will somehow work maybe
somehow the results will end up favoring
trump and i want to continue being chief
of staff or whatever i think it's the
same self-preservation that motivates
trump himself uh where they say well it
would it wouldn't have been my choice to
start this we won stuff but now that
trump did it what choice do they really
have other than quitting or getting
themselves fired it seems like it's not
really much of a choice at all
yeah i mean i don't believe that they
had some coming to jesus moment or some
religious or you know or belief system
that had them i agree with you that's
what we were saying early on you know in
the show when we were just chatting
about it it's um
it's all about their own preservation
and you really can't have an
administration run on self-preservation
versus upon what's doing right um for
not just yourself but right for the
country but
book after book on the final days of the
trump administration we hear a constant
theme right adults inside the
administration were on guard on election
night afraid of what trump was willing
to do to keep hold of power now what i
find astounding is that there were no
safeguards to prevent any of this from
actually happening other than relying on
people's sense of duty to the country
and to their position
now the fact that we didn't end up in a
bigger crisis i truly believe is more
luck than anything else discuss this
with me and my listeners yeah i
completely agree and you know uh
oftentimes when we think about history
we get this feeling of inevitability
that it went the way it it did and it
was certain to go that way in other
words the inputs that we had were
inevitably going to lead to the outcomes
that we had uh but it's really not like
that and of sometimes seemingly
irrelevant little details can can
significantly change the course of how
things go even the 2016 election at the
end of the day it was only a few you
know
it was relatively few votes in just a
few states that meant trump was
president instead of hillary clinton
even in 2020 it was slightly more but
still relatively few votes in a few
states that meant trump didn't win um
and i think that there was a real uh a
bullet dodged to a degree as bad as
things were
the pandemic is sort of evidence of that
i mean it's hard to imagine it in my
birth country of argentina one of the
worst pandemic responses in the world
but the us under trump was very very bad
and imagine if he had one what would
have become a vaccine distribution just
to give an example so as bad as it was i
agree that i don't know if it's luck or
odds it could have been dramatically
worse now you know that david you and i
have that in common by the way what
which argentina yeah my grandmother um
was born in argentina in argentina in
buenos aires just like you that's where
i was born that's incredible yeah yep um
that was a long time ago and i miss her
um dearly but yeah i noticed that with
um with you that you were born in
argentina specifically in buenos aires
you know the same as me abuela i do want
to ask you this though because since you
brought up argentina which right now is
really going through a world of pain as
it relates to this pandemic but there's
turmoil right now all over the world
right you turn on the television you see
what's going on in cuba you see what's
going on in haiti and in so many other
places around the world right donald is
right now using these issues that are
going on in no no two are actually the
same right one was about the execution
of the president in haiti um and what's
going on in cuba of course is um the
cost of living the fact that there's not
food there's no opportunity and so on so
every one of these countries have
various different issues that their
people are contending with but donald is
grouping them all together and whose
fault do you think it is
it's joe biden i would guess
it should okay i was gonna say or
communists or socialists no no it's all
joe biden's fault what are we doing
under my administration this never would
have happened right this is what he's
saying and what blows my mind for god's
sakes people put the [ __ ] visine in
your eyes so that you can see clearly
it's just not true
right under his administration nothing
would be different the world is the
world it moved in its direction that it
did the pandemic created a problem not
just here in the united states but
across the entire globe on top of that
cube has been going through its own
issues now of course the pandemic is not
helping right in order to you know bring
food and opportunity and uh you know the
rise in inflation over there and haiti
what do you think joe biden sent
somebody over there to kill the haitian
president but this is what trump does he
puts stuff out there which in essence is
true the world right now is upside down
but the untruth is what he would have
done to stop it
that this would never have happened with
me look at what's happening now with
russia with this new um our evil that
that group of hackers that somehow
managed to disappear
this would never happen under my
administration i would call up vladimir
i call putin and tell him to stop it
right and his people [ __ ] believe him
they believe him like the cult leader
that he is
what do we need to actually do in order
to stop this nonsense and now of course
everybody you know looking to companies
like facebook and they're looking to
companies like google to start to do
their
job in helping to curb all of this
misinformation disinformation but i
don't know if that's enough i don't know
if it's enough and it's just going to be
called suppression of speech sadly and
it'll become part of the narrative of
what's be what's being done wrong i mean
yeah the technique is called the fire
hose of falsehood you throw a bunch of
stuff out there it all sounds
overwhelming i mean look argentina's
chaotic and cuba and haiti then you step
back and you say wait argentina was
chaotic while trump was still president
haiti's been the poorest country in the
western hemisphere for decades now that
didn't change at all it didn't improve
at all when donald trump was president
cuba the situation in cuba since 1959
has been close to what it is right now
and in fact the sanctions that president
obama eased which president trump put
back in
certainly didn't help the situation in
cuba one bit but who's going to do that
right i mean fox news isn't going to say
let's break down these four or five
things you know add gas prices to it uh
which we understand why they're climbing
at grocery prices you throw it all
together and it sounds like pretty
convincing because that's a lot of stuff
that's bad only if you take it piece by
piece can you break it down and nobody's
really taking the time to do that
you can't because he throws so much [ __ ]
against the wall that you can't actually
piece it apart
right right
it's just impossible and yes yes i i am
waiting to see what this bad
administration is going to do let's just
use cuba as the example because we can
talk about each and every you know
country and what the united states needs
or can do in order to help you know
there's a whole slew of cuban americans
in this country and i could understand
and sympathize with them when you have
family members in another country that's
literally you know
miles from the floridian uh coastline
right that this is this is just
terrible and there has to be a way that
we can just put onto a barge just send
food over there let's just help them
with stu start small just do something
positive i mean we have enough food
there's billionaires that are out there
that have all forms of these different
political uh offshoots of their company
that they'll make donations to let's
just send a couple of plane loads of or
boatloads or cargo ships full of food
just so that people will relax if their
bellies are full let's just stop the
violence and stop the military attacking
the people there are so many things that
the president can do and work with work
with private industry i mean they have
these you know they have money that's
set aside in order to do this i mean
just take like the melinda gates
foundation as an example don't buy a
hundred million dollars worth of food
and send it over there rest assured rest
assured it'll calm things down for a
couple of days so people can start to
breathe and then you start to figure out
what else do we need to do we got to get
them vaccinations i think the whole
world needs to be vaccinated let's let's
finish with what we started here and
let's move let's move to the next
country in the next country i mean
that's that's who we are that's what
america is all about we're supposed to
be the country that helps everybody
that's that's just my opinion and i
would i would add to that also
let's ease those cuban sanctions that
trump put back in place because listen
the point since 59 was to use them to
try to get them to change their
government i'm not an authoritarian so i
don't i'm not a fan of the cuban regime
but the the the sanctions program has
failed and it's hurting the people let's
back off of that can you imagine if
biden actually did something that helped
the cuban people right now the first
thing that they would say is
is not bad
right cuban regime you've been lying to
us all these years they're the ones that
put food on our table they're the ones
that are helping us right
enough is enough and maybe there's an
internal change i i like you i'm not an
authoritarian on it but
that just seems to be logical you know
to me
[Music]
now some democrats believe that it's
time to go on the offensive and force
the gop to answer for their insanity by
portraying them as they are rightly
believing that the racism and the
conspiratorial ranting will be a huge
turn off to suburban voters and the more
the party makes that front and center
then the better it's going to be on
election day now that said
democratic party orthodoxy still
they still stress that kitchen sink
issues like jobs and infrastructure
have more impact than delving into the
gop's madness what's your point of view
on that this is really tough i was just
talking to the political scientist
rachel bittikoffer about this who's
really good on this issue
the republican party has abandoned
policy right if you even just look at
the videos from cpac last week there was
no economic program put forward it was
just joe biden socialism would be really
bad there was no uh
education policy put forward other than
we need to ban critical race theory in
school so
when they've abandoned policy
we might think oh democrats just come in
and they list policies and voters will
just be oh wow one side's talking about
you know nonsense and one side has
policies it'll be really clear democrats
will win 22 they'll win 24. it doesn't
work that way just doesn't work that way
the reason that these cultural issues
are what the right is focusing on is
because they see their followings
growing they see their donations growing
they see that it's actually winning them
elections and so i i am sort of
unclear at this point
if you can fight policy with better
policy that's a real clear win
if you're trying to throw policy when
half the country doesn't seem to care
and cares more about
owning the libs and memes
and calling things socialist i have no
idea how you fight against that i have
no idea either which is why i'm asking
you the question it blows my mind to see
what's going on because i personally
think that bill crystal summed up cpac
the best with his tweet yesterday and i
quote this weekend's confederacy of
dunces was a window into what
conservatism has become
there was of course no pushback from
anyone in the gop
nearly every speaker assured the cpac
attendees that they were all victims and
potential martyrs i end quote what do
you think it will take for the current
gop to abandon this suicide pact with
this magalunacy they have to start
losing and losing big and what's really
crazy is
under this package
they did lose the house in 2018
they lost the senate in 2020 and they
lost the white house in 2020.
for a lot of voters that would be enough
to say it failed
but when they say well
in 2018 it made sense because when you
win the white house in the first
midterms you always lose so they excuse
that and then they don't really believe
they lost the senate and and the
presidency in 2020 so they go well we
didn't even really lose there they're
not ready to abandon it yet so i think
sustained losses i think that the maga
people losing in 2022 will probably be
damaging to the movement and certainly
if 24 implodes but it's not it's going
to be sticky because you know 74 million
people voted for the guy and two-thirds
of them said say at least two-thirds say
they would do it again so they've not
lost the the will yet yeah i don't know
if they say the two-thirds was based
upon the fact that they're just staunch
republicans
or that they would actually
want it to be donald trump i mean that
was never really properly identified but
one thing for certain is that his base
of around 28
of the republican party that is his core
base now is that enough to win an
election no do i think donald trump's
going to run again in 2024 no for a host
of different reasons including
indictments
including indictments coming up and
including the fact that he knows that he
will lose the election again and his ego
his fragile ego cannot stomach another
loss and this [ __ ] line of it was
stolen stolen stolen notice what donald
trump always does
it's not about me they stole it from us
that's his line to his listeners but in
his mind and in his heart
it's all about him they stole this from
me and i want it back
that's super interesting because
especially in the maria bartoromo
interview on sunday
he seems to be using the language of a
guy who's running more than he has at
any point and my instinct was that there
were two things that were the most
likely to keep him from running one
his his picks in 22 all lose and he's
just powerless he loses political
capital that way
sees the writing on the wall and says
all my friends lost in 22 it's not
looking good for me in 24. the other
thing would be that his health is just
not suitable to running a campaign but
you think it's just it's not going to
happen for other reasons yeah for other
reasons one i believe that the district
attorney uh here in new york as well as
the attorney general tish james i
believe that indictments
additional indictments are on their way
superseding indictments as well
i also believe
that
the american people
have had enough
i really do now
that base of 28
appears to me to be dwindling and you
know that it is unfortunately not fast
enough for all of us you know it's a
problem that i like to term as googlized
right we all want things instantaneous
we want our information on this spot we
want you know we want our deliveries
through amazon on the spot right this is
this is what we've become we've become
this instant gratification society and
that doesn't happen with justice but
rest assured he his eponymous company
his kids so many people around him are
all going to face the court system
right that's my that's my opinion and
that's just the start of it you know i
also as i stated before his ego his
fragile ego will not allow him to accept
another loss right now as he speaks and
as he's talking about running again and
sort of floating the idea that's all
just part of the grift that's the money
grift and he's so [ __ ] good at it you
can i'm telling you david there is
nobody better at grifting money than
donald trump he has perfected it right
he really has he has perfected it as far
as a politician is concerned but i do
want to ask you this dave in a july 12
tweet you actually wrote it's still
legal to discriminate against people
based upon sexual orientation and gender
identity in 20 plus states but suddenly
republicans want to protect anti-vaxxers
in the same way race and religion are
protected what a country now if you
would discuss with me what it is in the
makeup of the gop that has created this
outright hostility towards vaccination
or do they just see a winning political
issue to rally their base and to raise
money it's so perplexing because this is
the vaccine they believe their dear
leader got for them
and yet
so many of them don't want it it it
really does not make any sense to me and
i think it's different things for
different people there are lots of
people who are just prone to
conspiratorial thinking so you hear
about magnetized vaccines you hear about
it'll make you infertile and they they
fall for that the other side of it is
that the vaccine rollout was a disaster
under trump and it's been really pretty
good under joe biden so it's become
biden wants me to get the vaccine
whether i believe it's the trump vaccine
or not as many of them do
biden's the guy who wants me to get it
and he says if i get it on the fourth of
july we can have a cookout and all of
this that nope that's joe biden telling
me how to live my life so i'm i'm
against that but the hypocrisy with the
non-discrimination stuff
the whole point of
for many of these folks saying
sexual orientation shouldn't be
protected is that they say people choose
their sexual orientation now i don't
know about you i don't remember ever
saying i'm going to decide today to like
girls i just always knew i was
heterosexual growing up so
i it doesn't seem to be a choice but if
that's a choice
getting vaccinated or not is a choice
why would we protect that why would we
regulate and tell the government
to force businesses to say
uh regardless of vaccine status you can
come in when it's it's it's a choice
it's there's no bigger choice than
getting or not getting a vaccine yeah i
don't even know how you put the two of
them together in the same sentence
vaccination and sexual orientation i
just don't see i don't see where there's
going to be an intersection of the lines
they just they just don't seem to be
ever going to cross pants it's it's like
talking about you know the difference
between a grape and a watermelon i mean
i just i truly don't understand it and
and your tweet really it got me thinking
and i was trying to really figure out
what the hell is going on here because
even after your answer i can't what
bothers me the most right is the fact
that these trump supporters and trump of
course himself believes that he should
be the recipient of the nobel peace
prize based upon
his amazing job with the coronavirus
right it's always about him it's him
it's him i should get the nobel peace
prize i know more than the scientists i
this i that i'm so tired of his eyes
already right but what bothers me the
most is we know that there's this new
delta variance that's out there and
there we've seen
because
numbers don't lie donald does but
numbers don't lie and the number of
people who are dying of the delta
variance of the coronavirus has spiked
over the course of the past couple of
weeks but here's what
facts that we know not innuendo not
donald trump's spouting more [ __ ]
here's what we know
we know that 98
of the people who died
over that course
are unvaccinated and only 2 percent are
vaccinated you know that's pretty good
numbers and if you had half a brain
you'd be running off to your doctor
right now to get the vaccination because
it clearly works
and the rest of it to me just doesn't
make any sense but what bothered me is
the fact that trump refused to
acknowledge that science is real that
the pandemic is real and he watched as
607 plus thousand americans died as a
result of his incompetence and that's
going to be on his soul for the rest of
his life and
let me let me tell you when he starts
calling it the china virus it is not we
need to start calling it what it is and
that's the trump virus but you know as
we're beginning to wind down i have just
two more questions for you david right
so i want to switch gears for a moment
i've been reading a lot about ron
desantis lately i despise ron desantis i
don't know about you but i i [ __ ]
look at him and i i've already broken
two television sets so i ever when i see
him now i just click it off because i
can't afford you know to buy a third one
right and how he's on this like
collision course to unseat trump and
claim the conservative throne for 2024.
now do you see the possibility in this
occurring and would we be better or
worse off with a desantis running versus
a potential trump 2024 is the cure to
trump in in essence now worse than the
disease at this point
yeah i uh the the con i think that
actually if you said to me the next
president will be trump or desantis
i think i say let's go with trump
because desantis is far more competent
desantis has a lot of the same terrible
instincts desantis has a lot of the same
amoral and immoral values and
perspectives but he's far more competent
and would be likely to get way more of
those things done whereas with donald
trump a lot of the things you know the
wall for example the rhetoric on the
wall well it just it was never going to
happen and it didn't happen okay because
the follow-through was simply not there
uh the concern with desantis is that
it's all the bad instincts of trump plus
the ability to actually get some of this
stuff implemented yeah for me i see it
as a very tough call i'm not sure which
one is worse and i'm not so sure that
the incompetence
is the offsetting factor to ron desantis
being more competent you know the
problem though is donald trump if in
fact that he takes the white house in
2024. the first thing he's going to do
is he's going to create a list of
individuals that he wants payback
that he just he can't help himself
that's just who donald trump is and he's
going to look to become an authoritarian
a dictator a supreme leader right a
monarch in this country and while ron
desantis is in my mind one very [ __ ]
up human being i'm not so sure that he
actually sees himself in that role as
like the kim jong-un of america and
donald trump though does so that's a
really tough call and let's just all
stop for one moment and just say a
prayer to whoever you pray to that
neither of these two [ __ ] end up on
the 2024 ballot you know for the
republican party so you know again as
you know we're now winding down the hour
my last question to you david i'm
curious what still keeps you up at night
when you're thinking about trump and the
larger maga movement or do you feel that
trump has been marginalized by um you
know by his loss and is more a rambling
loser you know than a threat at this
moment in time or do you still worry
about what he's actually capable of
unleashing after listening to his latest
cpac speech
if you would discuss this with my
listeners my concern is less about trump
and his harebrained ideas
it's about the fact that he still has so
many sycophantically devoted followers
because if you remove the followers and
trump has the same ideas and the same
microphone at the end of the day he's
speaking into the microphone in an empty
room and nobody's listening and so
my biggest concern is there's so many
wacky people that have run there's this
guy
uh glenn miller who's now in prison for
murder who i interviewed 10 years ago
who would run every election cycle and
his thing was the problem is the jews
that's crazy but he never built a
movement around it he never had a real
shot at winning anything he did
ultimately go and kill two people which
is insane it's horrifying but at the end
of the day trump has the room full of
people it's actually tens of millions of
people still even conservatively and so
what keeps me up at night is the fact
that after all of the losses 2018 2020
after the coveted mishandling after the
global humiliations that we're still
talking about could he win when in a
sane world the answer would be of course
he can't sadly the answer is he could
it's amazing i'm so in line with that
thought because
it's so rare
in our history
that a sitting president loses the
re-election
and loses it at the margin that trump
lost despite the fact that the number of
actual votes were less than what people
believe but the fact of the electoral
votes was such a landslide the same
landslide that he won by and yeah that
there's this group of sycophantic
followers that will follow him over the
cliff again i don't believe that trump
is going to be running i think that
there are too many intervening factors
right now that's going to be the loss of
his company you see what's happening
with weisselberg now you see what's
going to be happening with rudy who he's
throwing under the bus
removing weisselberg as a
director on over 30 corporations what's
going to happen when all of the loans
start coming due you know i i think he's
got
a whole slew of issues that he has to
contend with and i don't think that a
presidential run is going to be on his
on his mind
though
the craziest
thing that i've started hearing from
friends of mine is that don jr in his
whether it's his coked out stupor or his
drunken you know um stupor keeps talking
about he wants to run now in 2024 and
look i promise you this
if don jr ends up running for president
of the united states i'm putting my i'm
putting my hat in the ring because i
know exactly i know exactly how to take
don jr apart it's it's not difficult
either the same way i've been trying to
tell the democrats there are ways to
take donald trump apart right they just
don't do it they don't fight
they just don't fight hard enough they
don't fight smart enough
while i love the fact that joe wants to
be this empathetic president to all
as the president there's a ton of
responsibility sitting on your shoulders
one of which is to protect the republic
protect our democracy and uphold our
constitution and that starts with the
justice department and is
happy i was as i was that he had chosen
and um appointed merrick garland to be
our ag
right now i'm feeling very let down by
the guy so i'm certainly hoping that he
actually
steps it up
and starts behaving
i hate to say it more in the manner that
trump would have had them that the
republicans would have had them behave
because that's the only way to put an
end to the donald trumps the ron
desantis's the josh hawley's you know
the marjorie taylor greens of the world
the matt gates of the world you really
do need a justice department that's
going to hold each and every person
responsible for their own dirty deeds
and with that david i want to thank you
for joining us on maya culpa uh lastly
before i let you go what are you doing
these days
just hosting my show it's we we things
have been uh
it's a more than a full-time job yeah
hosting the show 150 radio and tv
stations we've got almost a million and
a half youtube subscribers um it's it's
all uh it's tying up all of my time and
what's the name of the show tell my
listeners maybe they want to listen to
it the david pakman show yeah find it
davidpakman.com
p-a-k-m-a-n all of my stuff is there
david i wish you the best i will speak
to you very soon if you ever need me for
anything you know where to find me i'm
on house arrest my pleasure
thank you for having me you got it david
and now for today's maya culpa donald
trump's latest turn towards extremism
reminds me of the parable i learned as a
grade school student about the scorpion
and the frog
for those of you who don't know the
story it goes something like this
a scorpion asks a frog to carry him over
a river the frog is afraid of being
stung but the scorpion argues that if it
did so both would sink and the scorpion
would drown
the frog then agrees but midway across
the river the scorpion does indeed sting
the frog dooming them both
when asked why the scorpion points out
that this is nature nobody is going to
confuse me with dr seuss but it's worth
pointing out the lesson here when it
comes to donald trump
who by now doesn't know his true nature
that said the gop thought who could swim
across the river with trump on his
shoulders and use his popular appeal and
fundraising ability to bolster the
party's fortunes
they could control him they thought he
would move back towards the middle once
elected the fact that none of this
happened and trump's stung his party
handlers repeatedly will go down in
history as one of the great political
horrors of this early century but what's
worse is that despite getting stung over
and over and over again the gop is lined
up to take more abuse
the upside they would argue is the
political power derived from trump but
the maga movement is nothing like the
apparatus and power built in the wake of
say ronald reagan who shared his victory
and brought scores of newly minted
republicans with him for the ride
the reagan revolution was a republican
revolution but any attempt to make
comparisons between him and trump are
simply asinine trump's power only
benefits donald trump and those he
directly shines his light upon
but that favor is conditional it comes
with strings and an oath of everlasting
loyalty to the man
the maga revolution is ultimately about
one man and one man only
it cannot scale because trump does not
want to share the light
he will never pass the baton and he
wants it only for himself
what he has created is the first modern
dictatorship in american history
the fact that he is out of power is
irrelevant
he still has the means and capacity to
inflict tremendous damage his latest
turn towards an even more extreme
iteration
is the most frightening version of
donald trump to date
the gop should have squashed him like a
[ __ ] bug when it still had the chance
now it's too late but history will judge
those who have let him operate poorly at
the moment that might be the best we can
hope for until the maga fever breaks
and thanks for listening
mayor culp is brought to you by audio up
midas touch and lsj media and it's
written and produced by jimmy jelenic
executive producers of jared gustat
jimmy jelenic myself michael cohen and
phil alberstadt our editor is lisa orkin
it may be a new day politically but
nowadays the landscape is more confusing
than ever
donald trump may have lost the battle
for the presidency but in many ways
trumpism is winning the war on the state
and local level
maya culpa is here to help guide you
through the wilderness and keep you
informed and let's face it we all want
trump rudy and the rest of these
seditious traitors to see justice and
folks it's coming so stay tuned as i
guide you through the twists and turns
of the criminal process that will
ultimately see them behind bars maya
culpa nothing but the truth
[Music]
tell the truth
[Music]
bring it on down
[Music]
up